thank you
[Music]
so did you guys know I mean first of all
we know that California is much
communist about straws right yeah yeah
because they're killing all the turtles
Right Turtles are really dying yeah
every single one every turtle is going
to heaven because of straws right
okay well now McDonald's is testing new
strawless Lids in an effort to reduce
the use of small plastic it's like the
Starbucks ones or the little opening oh
yeah the little openings that's not how
you do soda but sure I'll conform that's
gonna [__] McDonald's soda so bad
because you know their sodas they have
their own recipe number one their own
syrup don't syrup number two their straw
is the perfect like diameter and it's a
custom diameter and it tastes so [__]
good and that's why I go there an
opposite of Carl's Jr for a soda they
have a custom Diane yes it's way
different than any other straw I did not
know how fast food connoisseur I [__]
know this [__] there's straws in Hawaii
they don't have the yellow and red side
thing anymore why because they have to
use composer to boost straws oh so it's
like a clear compost you have to use
four straws drink one drink yeah they
keep breaking everything Hawaii it makes
more sense because they got more Turtles
out there they actually have Turtles but
you know what though that's what people
are coming
but you know what's crazy they don't
even have their own processing plant so
they have to [__] ship out the trash
anyway oh they do they don't even know
how to no it's a China regardless you
can't even recycle don't you like throw
it in the ocean what do you guys what do
you guys think about storm drones what's
your thick metal straws male straws I
have them at home I'm pretty chill with
them I'm trying to be environmentally
friendly while still preserving The
Taste I don't believe you but I but I I
do like that you're using milk you don't
believe actually talking about Metal
straws I'm Gonna Be A Nerd and say I
hated them until I found the ones that
have an extra little like ribbed lip at
the top because when they're just metal
they slip out and it tastes like metal
and then it's just like well while
you're sucking just and just [__] all
over your face is there anything like me
where I kind of chew on it a little bit
because I'm kind of weird yeah but then
with the metal straw I'm like oh [__]
okay you can't do it I can't do it hurt
your teeth we use bamboo bamboo straws
are pretty cool those are pretty
gangster that's what you have about help
oh
Jimmy has all bamboo shoes
but then you're [__] up all this
bamboo aren't you isn't Jimmy Waikiki
[__] up all his bamboo for it
okay guys hot take the only bad thing
about bamboo is it's not strong so then
like when you block Chinese straws
compared to yeah compared to plastic
bamboos like like when you have the
Jagged Edge you try to pop it through it
gets bent and [__] oh you end up wasting
more doing it okay this might be a hot
take but I think plastic is the best
substance for everything dude
I hear it's like it's like yeah you're
trying to make athletic clothes per
kilogram
it's [__] like a hundred times
stronger than steel dude come on what is
plastic made out of uh they use it from
like uh fossil fuel [__] like you know
probably for the marlaween yeah oil
should be more fossil synthetic oil
right synthetic [__] how do we get more
fossil fuels oh yeah dude we could solve
this plastic issue if we just had more
fossil fuels so we can get more Plastics
yeah that'd be sick because then you got
way way more Plastics yeah then we just
use it for everything and it's and
knowing I like that it's lightweight
we're seeing the turtle with the straw
in his mouth just one video dude I think
it's the nose that's the issue or in the
nose all it takes nose like into
sticking out like the whole life of
seeing Turtles and oceans I've never
seen a turtle with the straw I'll never
forget because they died the way that it
the propaganda [__] works on me I
remember seeing a [__] bird with like
the rings around its neck from like the
plastic yeah yeah oh yeah the six-pack
six pack yeah that's more like probable
and that [__] worked on me so well that
to this day I will not throw away those
rings and you know those Rings there's
the small Rings within the big rings I
even do that I know me too see that
actually happened to me I swam in Santa
Monica I came out and that thing was on
my foot so I'm like this is uncut I was
uncut it was on my foot on my distance
he almost drowned possible person like
this
right never had a straw between my toe
like you look right now yeah none of
that [__] [__] straws really changed
the way things taste I I think we should
bring that back and then whatever
species that can't survive [__] it dude
but whatever but I don't understand is
like you have a whole plastic ass cup
and then the straw is paper and it's
like how what the [__]
find the way to do everything yeah no
don't do it just leave me alone this
isn't about the auction is it the
auction what auction they found a
unopened McDonald's Straw from like 1970
something and it's it's I think the
current bid's like almost two grand
people have too much money people have
too much money how profound why would
you want that a person who hates the
[__] out of turtles and loves the [__]
you know it's crazier than straws now is
during the [__] mask days everyone
just throw their masks in the ocean yeah
and you're all there's always a floating
mask at the ocean well as long as you
cut the [__] ear holes this [__]
Mass oh [__] beach sand all over the
place van you go to Venice Santa
Monica's all over the place it's because
during covet people were [__] wearing
masks at the beach and [__] they're
swimming and it's gonna fall out it was
falling and they just made way too many
and they just they just had a study
about masks and how they said did [__]
all congrats did [__] all for you no
don't say that good job little boy you
did you did good a pack of 50 masks of
CVS is 35 what kind of mask you get yeah
bro that's the KN 95 not the n95 the
regular fabric ones that's how much they
were selling them oh at that time that's
like the Bros a couple weeks ago oh hell
no you still buy masks no I just once I
saw it Oh my God don't don't get at me
like that bro are you secretly say
Supreme on it you secretly getting in
the car and getting alone and wearing a
mask I know he misses it dude this is
the [__] lockdown feeling mentally
you feel better I had to go to the
hospital yesterday oh they make you wear
it over there and they make you wear a
[__] mat and I'm like and I'm sitting
in the waiting room wearing a [__]
mask and it's not it's like an
orthopedic surgeon spot it's not even
like a [__] medical it's like a
separate building and then the [__]
um the doctors walk in no masks and
they're looking at us and they're like
oh [__] I gotta move that's a Power Trip
right there it's so stupid when you go
to the doctor lunch rooms none of them
are wearing masks nobody's wearing shoes
even when uh when we had to go to the
drive through test because like when
whenever smack gets a acting thing she
has to go get it done then we go to the
drive-through one like we roll up not
wearing masks and then they go oh before
we roll the window down can you both put
masks before I stick this in your mouth
dude I bronchitis all over my car did
you guys see the jackass covid test no
no so they were I was watching this
documentary where they show it how like
they literally started shooting when the
kovic shutdown was so they're like okay
we have all these protocols we have a
cover safety officer and all this stuff
so all of them are like oh [__] I guess
like we have to do like all these tests
every single day before we shoot so they
the covet safety officer got everyone
together uh under like this big canopy
and there's like this big table in the
middle and everyone sat around and he
was like give it his safety brief before
he could even get a sentence through the
whole thing explodes just like jackass
style where they catch everyone off
guard and everyone just [__] flies
back so they need to give a [__] about
the code 50 if you just wanted to use
that as a as a gimmick
wow you should watch it favorite jackass
[__] it's just like walking down the
hallway and getting hit with a giant
[__] high five that is just so
[__] fun flower everywhere funniest
one oh that's my favorite one which one
which movie is that in I think the first
one oh I think the third one oh oh which
one is it look it up right you guys
still water uh masks on planes no well
you gotta yell at me man because you
work for the airlines don't you some
Airlines still make you do it which ones
there's so much data though now where
it's like okay covet tests are 40 faulty
so why even take those I mean I know I
understand you have to there's [__]
Mass don't do anything I'm like there's
all this data I'm like why don't we even
pretending it's a strange thing about it
like nobody apologizes for treating you
like [__] when now the new day is out
there oh yeah you got a vaccine you're
now a super spreader it's like only all
the data gets ignored man but I feel
like when it's like an Asian Airline
like they wear masks for different
reasons
that's what I mean I respect that so
like if I'm around them I'll wear a mask
but like it's not around Americans I'm
not gonna it's like walking through
Shibuya it's like they're freaking
they're like hey we've been doing this
[__] like 1970. yeah I just love looking
at grown-ass men in the grocery store
and I give them the [__] stink either
if you're American bro if you're
American and you're wearing a mask I'll
look at you like
people
I still see people if I know they're
like not from here I'm like that's you
you do your Asian American but American
yeah Asian American from America
okay
that's okay but what about a mask with a
Confederate flag on it
have you seen that like there's places
now that have signs outside that say no
masks allowed because of robberies and
[__] interesting that was happening all
covered long yeah they're like saying
you will not be allowed inside wearing a
mask due to increase in robbery what
like Walmart not Walmart but like I
think certain Banks that's when [__]
goes so far around the Sun that it comes
back and you're like what this is just
Bizarro world now probably a lot of like
dispensaries have too many robberies
kind of like how this article went from
straws to here covered robbery
foreign